[MUSIC PLAYING]
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Hello and
welcome to an exciting episode
of Google Developers Live.
My name is Arun Nagarajan.
DAN LAZIN: And my name, too.
No, actually, I'm Dan Lazin
I'm a tech writer here.
And my job is to make Arun's
life difficult.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
And in fact, he's going to be
very involved with some of the
stuff we're talking
about today.
Today it's a crash course, which
is all about diving deep
into a topic, an
exciting topic.
And today's topic, it
may be a little
cryptic for some of you.
And I did notice a lot of you
+1ed it and really were
excited about it, and some of
you probably was not clear.
It's called Apps Script
Import/Export.
We're going to be talking about
ways to get at your
source code from outside
of Apps Script
using the Drive API.
The Drive SDK.
DAN LAZIN: Yeah.
I think a lot of people
are going to
find this really useful.
When we were at Google I/O just
a few weeks ago, had a
lot of developers come up and
say they really loved the
power of Apps Script, but
they're more comfortable
working in a code environment
that's familiar to them, with
their own favorite
editor, their own
version control system.
This allows you to get access
to your Apps Script code and
keep it in your own
environment.
So it's a big new feature.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: I could totally
see why developers
want to run stuff in the cloud,
but they still want to
write the code on the laptops,
on their desktops, or
whichever workstation
that they have.
So really excited.
So let's get started.
Let's start taking a look
at what we've done.
So let's go here
to My Computer.
And the first thing that we're
going to talk about is where
you can find more information
about this API.
Let's go here to my screen,
and we'll say go to the
development environment.
So on the left-side panel,
you'll now see Development
Environment Guide section, which
was available before.
But what we've done is we've
added a new section.
And you wouldn't have
seen this unless you
refreshed just now.
It's importing and exporting
projects, and it's a great new
guide that we've added that'll
talk all about the stuff we'll
show you today.
And the idea is that with the
Drive SDK, which has been
around for quite a while now,
you will have APIs, the Files
API specifically, that will
allow you to get at your
source code.
So you can import it, you can
export it, you can do
interesting analysis with it,
integrate it with your source
control system using the tools
you write, or edit it in other
IDEs as well.
DAN LAZIN: And the reason we're
using the Drive SDK here
is that, as you're of course
all familiar with, your app
script code lives
in Google Drive.
It's a first-class file in
Google Drive just like a
Google Doc, a Google sheet, a
Google presentation, any of
those kinds of guys.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
And we specifically call this
out not to be confused with
the Drive service that's
in Apps Script.
I know the terminology may
get a little confusing.
But I think if you pay attention
to some of things
we're doing here, a lot of this
will become pretty clear.
DAN LAZIN: And really,
everything we're showing you
today is about Apps Script.
It's not in Apps Script.
All the calls that Arun's going
to be show you, these
are through the Drive SDK,
mostly through HTTP requests.
So don't think this is
code that you can
write in Apps Script.
Think of it as a way to
work with Apps Script
through the Drive SDK.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
All right.
So let's talk about all the
different parts of this
document right here.
So the first part is just
letting you know that we're
using the Drive SDK.
So if you aren't familiar
with it, it's actually
a really nice API.
You may find yourself using it
for getting at other files--
PDFs, Google Docs, et cetera.
I think it's a pretty
cool API.
In this case specifically,
we're going to be very
interested in the Files API.
And it's a REST-based API,
as Dan alluded to.
The first thing, though,
is that it does require
authorization.
So like a lot of Google APIs,
this uses OAuth 2.
And the Google Drive
documentation's got really
good samples to walk you
through how this works.
On top of that, the reason I
think this is really fun to
work with is they've given you
a lot of the tools, like
Inline API Explorer, that allows
you to get started
without having to know all
the details of OAuth.
And I think we'll get that
point across very soon.
DAN LAZIN: Like Apps Script,
you can try it out right in
your browser, make sure it's all
working before you go and
build your application.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's
really true.
Just like Apps Script, where you
can go to a Script Editor
and just start testing stuff
out, I think the API Explorer
gives you that flexibility.
Now, those of you that are
familiar with the OAuth, the
key point here is that there's
a new scope that we've added.
It's Drive.Scripts.
And in fact, this has
been out there for I
think a few weeks now.
And some people have
already noticed it.
And I've seen them refer to
this in Stack Overflow and
other forums.
And now you know what
it's there for.
This is to allow you to get
access to your actual source
in Apps Script, rather than
just the project file.
So this scope is really
important.
Without this scope, all you can
see is the existence of a
project, but you cannot
actually look at
the code in a project.
Because we think this new scope
will protect the user
further, because the
source may contain
sensitive data and so on.
So we want to make sure that
the user knows that an
application's doing this.
So let's get started.
The very first thing you may
want to do with your list of
projects that you may have--
and if you're like
us, you probably
have dozens of projects.
DAN LAZIN: Hundreds.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Hundreds of
projects in some cases.
I try to keep it a little bit
more neat than Dan, I guess.
DAN LAZIN: [LAUGHS]
A cluttered desk is good.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: I guess, yeah.
So the very first thing you'll
probably want to do is have an
API call available that lists
all your Apps Script projects.
So let's get started
with that.
From a technical standpoint,
what it is is an HTTP Get Call
with a authorization header
that includes
your OAuth 2 token.
And that will return back and
really nice JSON response that
lists items which represent
the projects.
And that'll give you-- and for
this example, you can see that
there's a mail merge project
with a MIME type of this
particular type, which is
vendor.google-apps.script.
So that's a really specific
MIME type that identifies
Google Apps Script.
And then you can see all sorts
of other things that include
things like the dates that it
was last viewed, a lot of
really useful metadata.
DAN LAZIN: To be clear, what the
end user is sending is the
very first of the code
snippets up there.
They're just sending that one
line broken across here--
oh, two lines, actually.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah,
the header.
Yup.
DAN LAZIN: HTTP Get request.
This large block of
JSON here is what
they get back in response.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yup.
I should be clear.
Yeah.
The request and response.
You can see there's a request.
Thankfully, because of things
like REST, it's really
straightforward.
You just encode your request and
then you get back a really
nice, detailed JSON response
that your application can do a
lot of useful things with.
And you can even see that this
has things like the owners.
All sorts of good stuff.
The important thing here is this
Export link, which we'll
talk about in just a minute.
So let's first make this simple
request, which just
lists our Google Apps
Script projects.
So to do that, what we'll do
is we'll go to the Google
Drive SDK reference.
And as I mentioned, this is
a really useful resource.
If you go to
developers.google.com/Drive,
you'll find all these things
that we're talking about here.
In fact, I think people that
want to write things like a
source control integration
example or exporting and
having it available in some
interesting syntax
highlighter.
There's some quick starts
available in different
languages that I think you'll
find really valuable here.
DAN LAZIN: So this Files
page here, how does a
person get to this page?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yup.
So if you go to
developers.google.com/Drive,
on the left-hand panel they've
got a really nice organization
much like Apps Script.
If you go to API Reference
and go to Files--
that's the very first API that
you'll often deal with--
and go to List.
So it matches the verbs
that you end up
dealing with in the API.
So List returns multiple
files back.
In our case, the Files
a project.
So the terminology, just
be careful with that.
DAN LAZIN: And just to be clear
on that terminology.
When we talk about a "project,"
we mean a single
entity that you save as one
unit in Google Drive.
The files are each of the
tabs within the project.
So you might have multiple code
files within a single
project in Apps Script, or you
might have a code file and an
HTML file if you're
serving a web app.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
A file in Drive term is what
shows up in the Drive Explorer
view, where you go to
drive.google.com, which
happens to be a project
in our world.
So the terminology is important
to understand there.
So let's go back here.
So let's make a call.
And they also really nicely
document all the different
parameters that the
API accepts.
So the very first thing we'll
do is we'll make a call.
And you can see that they have
a lot of quick start guides,
as far as in different
languages as well.
So we'll go here and
we'll say, we want
to now get our projects.
So thankfully, we have really
good samples that you can just
literally copy and paste.
So we want to copy
this guy here.
And we'll say go back to
my-- oh, there it is.
If I say MIME type
equals to that.
I do need to put
quotes around.
And you need to authorize it.
So this is how, like I said,
you need to write code to
handle this, or you can just
use their tools, which is
really nice.
And you can just check
this box for Google
Apps Script's behavior.
All right.
So I'm going to authorize
this.
The toggle is on.
I've already logged in,
so I don't need to
authorize it again.
If I hit Execute, what's going
to happen in just a couple
seconds here is the response
comes back from the API.
And you can see that it's
basically a Get followed by
the authorization header, which
is exactly what we show.
The user agent and all that
is really optional.
And then here is the list of
all the different projects
that I care for.
So you can see that
I have My Web App.
And then if I keep going down,
I'll see the next project,
which happens to be a dashboard
app that I built.
And so on.
So gets you the idea
that this is now a
functional sample request.
On top of that, since the Drive
SDK has a lot of really
nice features, like you
can say, only show me
the top five results.
Or you could say, only show
me where I am the owner.
So a really nice, simple thing
you could do is say "and 'me'
in owners." It kind of sounds
weird, but the API is
actually, I think when you
execute it, the results make a
lot of sense.
"And 'me'" is a special
keyword for the person
authenticated.
So that way, you can write a
generic filter that works for
whoever's at the keyboard rather
than have them type in
their email address or
something like that.
DAN LAZIN: And the reason you'd
want to add this me and
owners parameter is that when
you search Google Drive, it's
just like going to Google
Drive and typing
in the search box.
If you have other people who've
shared files with you--
Arun's sharing sample code
with me all the time--
I'm going to see Arun's projects
in my Google Drive
search results.
Realistically, I don't care
about this guy's code.
I want to see my stuff.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
Depending on you tools and use
cases, those filters may make
a lot of difference in
what comes back.
So now we have the same
response back.
You can see that the HTTP
request now has the additional
parameters in the URL.
So really straightforward.
What we've done so far is only
demonstrate to you that Apps
Script projects are accessible
through the Drive SDK.
All right.
DAN LAZIN: Let's go over that
query term just one more time.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Sure.
DAN LAZIN: In case
people missed it.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
So Q is there, the query
string, where a lot of
different useful fields
of features can go in.
In fact, they have a really nice
documentation page for
that as well somewhere
up here.
Searching for Files.
You should take a
look at that.
And that'll talk about
all the different
properties you could use.
And then in our case, since
we're saying only give us
Google Apps Script projects,
it's really important to
specify that through
the MIME type.
DAN LAZIN: So just Q MIME type
equals application/VND/ and
then the Google Apps
Script MIME type.
And then in this optional case,
we added "me" in owners.
That's all you need to
fill in is the Q
field here after you've--
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Zoom in a little
bit more. --and then
click the OAuth button.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yep.
Really straightforward.
So that ought to give you the
confidence that your projects
now are accessible
through an API.
And in our example here, we're
just using the API Explorer.
But thankfully, the Drive SDK
has some really good quick
start code snippets that you can
use to get used to calling
it from the command line, or
writing a web app in Java, or
in PHP to grab the same thing.
And in our example, in fact, for
the very next thing that
we're going to show you,
we're going to use a
simple Python app.
And I'm not a Python whiz, but
thankfully, because there's a
lot of really good sample code
for me to get started,
including some companion videos,
this is actually
really straightforward to do.
So what we'll do next is we'll
use a simple Python command
line app that given
a project ID--
I should say, a file ID of
the Drive response--
it'll fetch that project and
mimic that structure in my
local file system.
DAN LAZIN: Cool.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Wouldn't
that be great.
Let's go take a look.
DAN LAZIN: And that's all you're
going to need to then
hook up that local file to
either your local code
repository, maybe your GitHub
repo, plug it into the code
editor of your choice.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Do all sorts
of things with it.
DAN LAZIN: Cool.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So let me
just show you the code.
I used the quick start.
And we're going to be sharing
this with this you, so we want
to clean this up and make
sure that its shareable.
DAN LAZIN: This Python sample
isn't available on the page
that we're showing
you quite yet.
We'll have it up there maybe
in a couple days, and we'll
update this YouTube video's
description with a link to
this Python app as well.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: We definitely
want to make this available.
And this example I started based
on this quick start.
So you'll see a lot of
similarity in that code.
And in fact, I would recommend
just watching this video just
a few minutes to get a sense for
all the steps required to
get to the point where I'm at--
which I'm going to skip
in the interest of time.
But the very first thing
you need do is
enable the Drive API.
You need to install a couple
of libraries so that the
Python app can work
really seamlessly.
And then there's this process
of getting the OAuth token
established.
And that's a one-time process,
because the library actually
takes care of refreshing it
and keeping it up-to-date.
So it's actually really nice.
And the process requires
basically you authorizing a
URL once, and copying
and pasting a token
into a command line.
And it's good to
go from there.
So you can actually schedule
this app to run every hour,
you can run it on a keyboard
shortcut, and so on.
So the run the sample, and
that's what we're going to do.
So let's go take a
look at the code.
So we're going to do is I have
a couple of functions.
One is called Download
Project.
You can imagine what
that does.
And one called Update Project,
which we'll get
to in a little bit.
Let's start with Download
Project.
So this is the project that
I want to download.
How did I get the project ID?
The safest way to get
the project ID is
back from the API.
So this ID will match the
ID that you'll see here.
So the 1TU.
If I just copy this guy and
paste this in here, they're
the same exact thing.
And before I run, but
let's actually take
a look at the code.
So what I have here is basically
a very simple sample
that is two files and says
"Hello world." But this could
be half a dozen files, or all
the code can be in one file.
Really however you want
to organize it.
So let's go and take a look
at the sample here.
So what we're going to do is go
into my command prompt, and
let me just make sure the right
code is initialized.
So we're going to run Download
Project when I run this code.
So I'm going to say Python,
and I think it's
drivefiles.py.
I'm going to run it.
And it's not going to do much.
It's going to very
quickly run.
But then you can see that behind
the scenes this folder
was created without me having
to do anything.
If I go in there, there's
three files.
The code.js, index.html,
and something called
manifest.json.
I'll explain that in a second.
But these are the two things
that I really care for.
And let's actually go into
my Sublime editor here.
And you can see that
I have this code
available right there.
DAN LAZIN: That's awesome.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Zoom in there
and zoom in there.
You can see that that's
the code.
DAN LAZIN: So helpful
to so many people.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And just the
fact that I can come in here
and Sublime does a really good
job of syntax highlighting,
and they have some really nice
macros that you can run that
allow you to do auto-completion
to a lot of
useful JavaScript syntaxes that
I think sometimes are
hard to type.
And let's do a quick example
where we actually flip this
back and send it back, and then
we'll review the code.
So I'll just say, let's say
that I want a logger.log.
You can see that it's trying
to help me, but it doesn't
know the API that well.
So I'll say "hi dan!"
and save this.
DAN LAZIN: Semicolon, Arun!
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Ah,
you don't need it.
[LAUGHTER]
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And then I go
back into my Python sample.
And instead of downloading it,
what I'll do is I'll actually
upload that.
And for this, I just need the
folder name as well, because
that's what's important.
And I'll go back to my command
prompt, and I'll say run that
same thing.
And you can make this much
more configurable.
And that's one of the reasons
we're not publishing the code
right away, because it should
be a command line parameter.
We figure it's more important
to get the documentation out
to you so that you can start
doing some really cool things.
And I ran the code again.
And now let's go [INAUDIBLE]
with the script editor.
And we do need to reload
the script editor.
Unfortunately, it doesn't
update live like
it would for Docs.
But there it is.
The code that I edited in my
offline editor, after I ran a
little tool that was pretty
immediate, I'm able to see
that code on my script editor
as if another person on
another browser somewhere
is typing in that code.
DAN LAZIN: You're your
own collaborator now.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: [LAUGHS]
So that's really powerful
to be able to do that.
Now you can start really
thinking about all sorts of
really cool use cases.
Hopefully you're seeing that the
fact that I can edit this
code is really nice,
in Sublime.
But really, I thing where the
power comes in is if you start
thinking about, OK, now I can
write a little synchronization
tool that just copies all my
folders of projects for all
backup purposes.
Or automatically publishers to a
GitHub repo every hour after
checking for updates.
Or something along
those lines.
And this is purely a
developer feature.
So this is great for all you
developers that really want to
use the tools that you have.
If you have some Apps Script
code calling App Engine code,
and you're used to using a
particular eclipse set up,
maybe there's some interesting
things you could do here to
make that all work.
DAN LAZIN: Now from what I
understand, this is only going
to work for Apps Script files
that are standalone in Drive.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
That's right.
DAN LAZIN: You can't use
this to get access to a
container-bound script like
one that's embedded in the
spreadsheet or embedded
in Google Docs.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
The simple rule of thumb is if
you can see the script project
in your Drive, those projects
are exportable and importable.
At this point, there's no way
to get at the project that's
associated to a particular
document or form or
spreadsheet.
But if you have a library,
that is shared.
Hopefully this also improves
some of the resuability
patterns around libraries.
Yeah.
That is the case today.
And we look forward to hearing
your feedback to see what
makes sense and how we can
improve this further.
By way of limitations, there's
a couple of other limitations
I'd like to quickly
point out as well.
So in our API section in the
API guide, the very last
section is called Limitations.
Like any good API, we
want to be honest.
And there are a few things that
we can do right away.
But hopefully by us explaining
this all makes sense.
The very first thing, like I
mentioned, container-bound
scripts cannot be accessed
through the API at this point.
You can only get at the source
code, not the project
properties.
And certain actions, like
publishing and versioning, are
not quite available
at this point.
DAN LAZIN: So you can't get your
ScriptDb as part of this,
for example.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: At
this point, yeah.
Yeah.
So it's only the source
code that's--
DAN LAZIN: But if you were
using, for example, a
spreadsheet as a data source,
because the spreadsheet lives
in Google Drive, you can
actually use a variation of
this technique to grab a copy
of your spreadsheet.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: You could
do some pretty
cool things like that.
DAN LAZIN: You'd have
to export it first.
Not live Google Drive--
ARUN NAGARAJAN: [LAUGHS]
Dan's the one with
the crazy ideas.
DAN LAZIN: Yeah, yeah.
Let's not confuse people.
Back to Arun.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So let's take
a look at what some of the
things that happened behind
the scenes are.
So we showed you what can be
done, a quick demo of that.
We showed you some of the
limitations that you have to
be aware of.
Now let's talk about some of
the details of how this all
worked out.
So before I show you the Python
code, let me show you
the APIs that behind the
scenes were exchanged.
The very first thing to
keep in mind is the--
let me just come back here.
OK.
So I talked about how you could
list your projects.
Once you listed your project,
one of the things that you get
back that's really
important is this
concept for Export Links.
Export Links is actually a
generic Google Drive feature.
So for instance, a Google
document can be
exported to a PDF.
That link is described within
the export links for that
document object in
the response.
So for a Google Apps Script
project, the only export link
is a JSON file.
So that's something that
you have to know about.
So if you have an
already-existing Google Drive
integration, taking advantage
of some of the things that
we're doing here with Apps
Script is actually really
straightforward.
So we didn't invent anything
brand new there.
What we did have to make up
here, because it's a brand-new
capability, is the URL where the
export link points to is a
new URL that you'll see under
script.google.com/Feeds.
And that has an export end
point, where it'll essentially
get the ID of the file, followed
by the format.
And only supported
format is JSON.
So if you're trying other
formats, you'll get an error.
And you'll use the same
authorization header, the same
OAuth credentials, to
get at this content.
And the response you'll
get back is a new
type of JSON response.
This one essentially is
an array of files.
And it's a pretty extensible
format.
And hopefully we'll
keep pushing the
capabilities of this.
But for now, it's a file
object that is
made up of four things--
the ID, the internal identifier
of this file.
This is the file within
the project.
The type of file, whether
it's a JavaScript
file or an HTML file.
The name of the file, code.gs,
or index.html.
And then really, the most
important part, which is the
actual source code.
So we encode this to make
it friendly with JSON.
And we'll describe some
the details of--
the client libraries take
care of parsing that.
But if you are hand-parsing
these things, just make sure
your accounting for
the JSON-friendly
encoding that we do.
And you can actually eyeball
this, and you can see what
it's doing.
So you can see that
there's the doGet.
There's the quotes.
And then here's the HTML.
We encoded again.
So actually, pretty easy
to look at this.
And we actually describe what
they are as well down here.
The only two types you'll see
today are ServerJS and HTML.
And this will mimic what
you can do from here.
So that's how I was able
to get the file.
As far sending it back
up, now this has
some of its own nuances.
We do what's called an
HTTP Put request.
And that's updating something
in place.
And the important thing here
is to specify the type of
content you're, putting HTTP
header of content type.
And this is an important thing
to remember if you're
handwriting this.
So the fact that it is
a VND Google Apps
Script, plus JSON--
the plus is a normal way we
describe the alternative type
we're uploading that.
Because we're not actually
uploading this.
We're uploading this in
the format of JSON.
That's what that signifies.
And again, this will look like
what you downloaded.
Now, there are a lot of things
that probably comes to mind.
You're probably asking,
how do I delete a
file within a project?
How do I rename them?
How do I create a new one?
And it's all based on state.
Well, not state.
It's based on IDs,
I should say.
If you send us a file without
an ID or an ID that we don't
know, that means create
a new file.
So we'll just assume that you
want a new file created.
If you don't send us a file
that we have on the server
side, that means you don't
want that file retained.
As in delete.
DAN LAZIN: That means if you
have a multi-file project,
you've got to send back every
file every time, not just the
file you just updated
right now.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
DAN LAZIN: Otherwise
you're [INAUDIBLE].
ARUN NAGARAJAN: You should take
advantage of the GZIP
compression that
the API offers.
But it does mean that there is
a bunch of data that's going
back and forth at this point.
So be careful.
Make sure that you're sending
back up the whole thing rather
than just what you changed.
The patch semantics are not
available at this point.
And renaming, as you can
imagine, if you keep the ID
the same and change the name,
we know that it's the same
file, you're just calling
it something different.
DAN LAZIN: If I try to keep the
same ID but change it from
a ServerJS file to an HTML file,
is that going to work?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Nope.
Doesn't work.
I would've expected that to
work as well so I tried it
out, but the UI doesn't
support it.
So you cannot convert
a file here.
So they can't change this.
So a lot of ways it mimics
what the UI provides.
So just keep that in mind.
The API is not as foolproof
as the UI, for instance.
If we block you from deleting
the last file, the API does
give you error messages.
So you'll have to look at it
and make sure that you're
doing the appropriate things.
The UI is much friendlier
towards mistakes and guides
you to the right thing.
And then the last thing
is creating a new
project from scratch.
So we didn't show you
this in the example.
This is a bit more advanced.
This is you want to have a new
file in your drive created
without the user taking any
action at all as the user.
And for this, you use what's
called a Post request.
And again, it's the same
URL without any ID.
So there's no file ID in this
case, because you're creating
a brand new one.
The important thing here
is this Convert
Equal to True parameter.
So that is, by default,
off in the API.
Since you're sending up a JSON
and converting it to an Apps
Script app, you do need
to sent that in.
And the post parameters, the
post body, will look just like
the other body that
you've seen.
DAN LAZIN: Except there, you're
not sending IDs for the
files [INAUDIBLE],
because they're
all a brand new creation.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
Exactly.
And this will create a project
called Untitled in your drive.
So there are ways where you can
include metadata in the
creation part itself.
And for that, we really
recommend
using the client libraries.
Because that's actually
two requests--
one for the metadata and
one for the media.
So just keep that in mind.
DAN LAZIN: Or just write an app
scripts to find any new
untitled projects [INAUDIBLE].
ARUN NAGARAJAN: [LAUGHS]
Yeah.
That's another way to
solve that problem.
Leave it to Dan.
So now, let's take a look
at how we did this
in the Python example.
Zoom out a little bit.
So again, this is something
that we'll clean up
and share with you.
But let's take a look at
the download part.
Here's what we're doing.
We're touching drive_service
is the wrapper that we get
from the client library.
And we're very easily able to
just say, get me all the files
where this ID matches.
So it's really straightforward
if you
use the client libraries.
In fact, none of the code here
will actually do any REST
calls itself.
We're just using the Python
Client libraries.
And say Execute on it.
And once I get the response
back, I can just say give me
the export links.
And then particularly, give me
the application/JSON link.
And then you're able to very
quickly get the download URL.
And then go ahead and
get that as well.
So now I have my content
of the project.
What we're doing next is
creating a folder if it
doesn't exist.
And deleting any files in the
folder if it's already there
so that new files can
get copied over.
Again, you might have
a lot of different
optimization options here.
We're storing the manifest.
And I'll come back to
this, because it's
required for the upload.
And then I'm just iterating
through all the
files that we get back.
And then we're just creating the
file with the appropriate
extension--
.js or .html.
Your rules apply here as well.
The very last thing that we do
is make sure we write the
source code into it.
Ultimately do that.
And since we're using the client
libraries and Python's
JSON parsing capabilities,
it takes care of all the
encoding/decoding stuff.
So I get this nice look here
rather than this one-line
representation of that.
Which is great.
And then the last part I'll
show is the upload part.
What we're doing here
is we're actually
opening up the manifest.
And the manifest is important,
because I'm not storing the
file IDs anywhere else.
So I was thinking about
different ways to solve this.
Potentially, I could have hidden
it in the first line of
the file itself, or I could
name the file its ID, or
something along those lines.
But it's lot easier to
just have a manifest
file for the demo.
And again, this is where I feel
like the developers that
are going to be building apps
will really shine and do
something pretty cool
and creative.
And what I'm doing here is I'm
just iterating through the
manifest and copying back into
the manifest the source code
to send back up.
I'm storing it temporarily, and
then using the media file
upload capability from the
client library, giving it the
file to upload.
What I'm also doing is including
the metadata about
it, like the MIME type
and things like that.
And here's where I could
potentially rename the project
as well, which is a really
nice capability.
And then ultimately, just
a single call to say
files.update this particular
project.
And then here's the body,
and here's the media.
Really straightforward.
We're talking about one
hundred-odd lines of code in
Python, which is a pretty
succinct language to begin.
With but even in Java or PHP,
you'll find yourself doing
this in a lot less lines of
code than you'd expect.
And this is just a very simple
synchronization utility for a
particular folder
and a project.
But we think that there's going
to be some really useful
stuff that people will end
up building with this.
DAN LAZIN: It's going to be a
race to see who can come up
with the best implementation.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: I think
we're out of time.
We're really excited to see what
you can build with this.
Find us on Stack Overflow, find
us on Google+, tell us
what you're going to be
building, what you've tried,
and any issues you have.
Feel free to log it in
the issue tracker.
We do ask you to figure out
whether it's a Drive issue or
an Apps Script issue.
And you can do that using all
the tools I described.
The API's Explorer's
a really good tool.
That will really make sure
that you get the right
response from the right people,
rather than having to
have us triage it.
But I think with this video
and hopefully this
documentation page with we will
keep updating and adding
more content and samples to.
I think that was all we
wanted to talk about.
DAN LAZIN: Yeah.
That looks really good.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Cool.
Thank you very much.
DAN LAZIN: Excited to see
what you guys do.
Apps Script forever.
[MUSIC PLAYING]